Michael Cohen Je ne regrette pas son excuse
qui était intelligent vous pauvre Donald Trump a
dit l'impôt Ibaka ATO caldas j'ai échoué
la procédure électorale le juré a plaidé le diesel
j'ai honte parce que je sais ce que mr.
Trump est qu'il est raciste c'est un escroc
et c'est un tricheur
Donald Trump déclare Michael Cohen son
assistant Ernest Coe il aidera le
panier devrait tous être dans le chêne arrêter des
gens à wha et il m'a dit que les noirs
ne voteraient jamais  pour lui parce
qu'ils étaient trop stupides le PZ vers le bas d'un ton
s - Michael Cohen L fou numérique le
PE Satta
moulin de la vaca étouffement d'alessio
extra conjugal ensembles impartis suis-je
terrible voir Bertram Allah il a allumé un
Rashida le président des États-
Unis ainsi  a écrit un chèque personnel pour
le paiement de l'argent du silence dans le cadre d'un
stratagème criminel visant à violer
les lois sur le financement des campagnes Ernest Coe suppose que nous Cohen
pouvons le président America my Alderney
la dent postérieure litical il toujours
prêt villes de la vallée avec nous :
Oh Tricia comme Utila Pisgah Donald  Trump
graisse si elle dit que sa Russie voit maintenant que
m.  Trump a gonflé ses actifs totaux lorsqu'il
a servi ses objectifs et a dégonflé ses
actifs pour réduire ses impôts fonciers
une question rapide
dame publique an ala pacha Michael Cohen
il y avait un congrès allemand Co à Aix-la-Chapelle la
capacité des enfants fixe toujours notre nourriture mon
manioc une raison pour laquelle il est un  faux témoin sa
présence ici est une parodie tu es un
menteur pathologique je suis responsable de
Michael Cohen hey Paul he Biblica to
Sookie's we've ever gleameil Donald
Trump seniors rule come mwah parce que j'ai
fait la même chose que tu fais maintenant
pendant dix ans
j'ai protégé mr.  Trump pendant dix ans
Jeff empanada sound jusqu'à ce que Saku vous
faites mama Protege mr.  Trump ouais
Michael Cohen a confirmé Trump Saavik
WikiLeaks alejandra public ils ne sont que
le démocrate cool et sain sur le
messie Je n'utiliserais pas le mot
collusion peut Alenia voir l'
illusion publique du président COO avoir un problème clair
et c'est le peuple américain démocrates
un scandale de mime disco est  un paranormal le
prisme est un criminel pourrait répéter vers le bas
ils m'appellent ce que nous avons ici mr.
le président est une conduite criminelle dans la
poursuite de la plus haute fonction publique d'
accord Michael Cohen plaisirs
Méthodologie Ottumwa Porvenir vivre près du
chercheur de liberté personnelle Donald Trump